through every challenge alex's wife jean
and their family
were his inspiration to fight on there
were moments of great pain
days when certain bodily functions no
longer functioned
and sudden massive attacks of great
depression
that made me wonder if it really was
worth fighting on
but i brushed that aside quickly because
that would have been a massive betrayal
a betrayal of my wife and soul mate jean
who has given her all
to help me survive jean was the first
person alex told about his cancer
diagnosis
she told abc's michael strahan that it
was tough watching him suffer
i'd say for me it's when i see him in
pain and i can't help him
and uh when he doesn't eat right
when he has too much diet soda
i'm 79. if you get to be 79 and be in as
good a shape as
wait a minute i'm not in a great shape
i blew that one trebek alex and jean met
at a party in new york
they married in 1990 when he was 49 and
she was 26.
alex and jean were parents to two kids
son matthew and daughter emily who grew
up
out of the hollywood spotlight this is
my daughter emily
emily and matthew hung out on the
jeopardy set as kids
emily created this sign for alex's
dressing room door that reads in the
form of a question
what is the world's best dad i
started the series and said this is a
good show but i don't think in terms of
how many years will this go on although
now i'm thinking more and more along
those lines because i've
made some major investments in homes and
cars and things like that and i've got
two kids who are growing up
alex also raised his stepdaughter nikki
from his first marriage
she works at jeopardy matthew owns a
mexican restaurant in new york city
while emily flips houses when alex was
undergoing cancer treatment
he and gene were honored by fordham
university matthew's alma mater
i certainly want to give great thanks to
fordham university
for helping to develop our son matthew's
personhood on that night his voice horse
alex spoke about how he was grateful for
all the prayers he'd received
during his battle with cancer prayer
has a lot of power
and if there's one thing i have
discovered
in the past year it is that
power of prayer if you have compassion
in your heart everything is possible